se faire bien voir guillaume lance de
fausses invitations chroniqueur pour
assister à des matchs de parc des
princes une fois qu'ils ont dit ok il
répond désolé mais c'est trop tard
alors ça c'est moi qui ai balancé oui
bâlois du poids il ya que guti balancé à
la wii et moi c'était pays ma vie de
gentiment mais elle me dit écoute je
viens tu devrais venir être pas tout
j'ai deux places pour toi en loge vip au
parc des princes la chorale est génial
mais là j'ai fait donc à la rentrée
vient le voir je suis dit écoute
guillaume merci de temps l'invitation
c'est génial le prochain match on est
dispo et là il dit à des infos sur miss
france alors je dis mais qu'est ce tu
veux qu'ils se donnent comme info
service et j'en ai g2 naciri tu as des
infos sur quesada tas d'infos sur machin
c'est en fait j'ai dit mais j'ai pas
d'infos et me dit pas d'un faux pas de
placer
[Applaudissements]